hey everybody welcome back to park
attacks today i'm going to try my hands
at dragon valley the scenario states
that the pillar mountains in this
chinese valley provide a picturesque but
extremely difficult terrain for
nature-themed attractions it is your
task to turn this unusual landscape into
a blossoming theme park
without destroying the geological
features that characterize it and the
goals are to get an experiences rating
of at least 80 have 800 guests in the
park and some optional goals that we can
probably use to make an extra bit of
money now
i'm gonna go ahead and say that this is
probably the most difficult scenario in
the whole game based on uh
well not generally but definitely when
it comes to the terrain because as you
can see it is very unusual and there's a
lot of very difficult terrain that we
have to play with not to mention that
the map is also quite limited it can be
very hard to see exactly where
our borders
start and end
but as you can tell it's kind of going
around these mountains here
and all the way back here and then we
end up here at the entrance so there's
definitely quite some land but it's it's
all kind of difficult to work with and
another thing to mention uh
there we go there is no land available
for purchase but we also cannot
terraform as you can see it's just
completely
not an option um which means that this
is also going to be a bit harder in that
sense we can't flatten anything we're
gonna have to work with the terrain that
we have why the chinese authorities
decided that it's okay to build theme
parks and buildings here uh but not to
change anything else about this
geological stuff you know it already
seems like we're stepping on unesco
heritage grounds here i'm not entirely
sure but you know
we can make some money off of it so why
complain also i have to say that this
scenario is based on the real world
pillar mountains uh their name
i'm definitely going to butcher but
they're called jung jiajie and it's a
national park in china there's
definitely not going to be any amusement
parks in real life there but there is an
interesting gondola and also an elevator
that looks really cool definitely an
awesome travel location
anyway let's get started and see what we
can make of this
all right so one second into this video
and i already need to fact check myself
there are a whopping three gondolas in
zhang national park in real life which
is absolutely insane and
i have talked about this in videos
before but i don't think i have in
parkitect video so here goes anyway
i find this a really cool revelation
because i am super into gondolas
chairlifts and any kind of roadway so
these gondolas look so interesting
they've got a bunch of lightner and
doppelmayer gondolas going through the
valleys reaching the cliff tops which
is absolutely the dream hopefully one
day you know i'll make it out there we
never know but for now i just found it a
super interesting and intriguing fact
there's actually also a mod for
parchitects
with chairlifts and gondolas which looks
really good i've already tried it before
and it works super well unfortunately i
am sticking to the vanilla game for this
campaign mode but
if i were to use mods and if you're
playing this campaign yourself and
you're allowing yourself to use some
mods i would highly recommend trying out
the chairlift gondola mod for this map
because it seems like a perfect fit and
i think you can probably do some really
interesting things with it
anyway i'm already heading very much off
topic as per usual at the start of this
video so let's actually get to the
subject at hand
my first building in this scenario and
i know i've said this before but i think
the first building and also some of the
other first buildings that you build in
any given scenario for me at least are
always kind of a a trial an experiment
to see what kind of style you can stick
with for the rest of the scenario
obviously
every scenario either has a different
theme or you want to force yourself to
have a different take on a theme that
you've already done before so for me
these kinds of first buildings are
always a nice test run to see what else
i can do differently this time and if
there are any more
different techniques and stuff like that
that i can invent and this time around i
decided to try and go for a small
chinese pavilion well i say small but
it's actually quite large here at the
entrance to cover an information stand
and this was already my first attempt at
a new way of doing asian roofs
asian roofs have always been one of my
favorite
challenges in parchitects just because
it's something that the game isn't
really made for
typically in real life asian roofs are
these large overhanging roofs with lots
of decoration and curves
and those are all just things that are
really hard to get around in the blocky
stylized and very much grid based world
of parkitect but in this case i
came up with a strategy to try and get
around that a little bit and add some
more flair and interesting tidbits to
these roofs and that is to use diagonal
basic art shapes to try and make some of
the riches and decorations on this roof
and even build an entire top part of the
roof
using the basic shapes only and i think
it actually works out quite all right
i'm pretty happy with the final results
here you can see that we get an
interesting shape with definitely those
kind of
very stylized decorations that you
typically see on the corners of chinese
roofs where they could put maybe even
some dragon heads or similar decorations
and while it definitely doesn't look
exactly the part i think zoomed out
enough and and given the very stylized
art style of parkitect it works well
enough i was also trying to go out of my
way to come up with a new way to do
asian style roofs because
there have been
many occasions already where i've tried
to do asian style roofs the first being
for the initial parkitect playthrough
that i did uh once park text came in
early access on steam then of course i
made the pagoda valley scenario for the
base game campaign and sakura gardens as
well
and then when it came to my playthrough
on youtube pagoda valley was one of my
first attempts at trying a new kind of
japanese architecture and sakura gardens
for me up till now actually is actually
one of my favorite scenarios in terms of
how the park turned out and
my favorite
tackle of any general east asian theme
so far i feel like that was really the
point where i kind of finally understood
how to properly do asian roofs in
parkitect
and
now that i got to this scenario i really
wanted to come up with a different way
to do it
also given the fact that every asian or
at least east asian style scenario
in park tech that i've done so far has
all been japanese and this time i'm
having to give chinese a go which is
something that i'm not quite as used to
as japanese
um i really wanted to you know do it
differently now obviously i've made this
scenario already so i've done a little
bit of practice already you can see
there's an entrance building with a
golden roof and there's also
one building to the left here
actually standing just outside the park
borders but giving some extra decoration
to this map
so those were kind of some black some
practice runs as well but those still
use the general approach of roofs that i
used in sakura gardens as well so
this whole
basic shape strategy that i went with
for the first building in the scenario
is a very new thing anyway i need to
catch up with the time lapse i see
because i have long been building a
roller coaster and i have barely
commented about it
so you start off this scenario with a
bunch of rides that i now realize i
forgot to show off at the start of this
video but not to worry we'll get back to
what i have available in the next
section of this video but for now all
that's important to know is that we
start off with the mac rides extreme
spinner and
to be honest
whenever
i start playing a scenario in this dlc
and i know the extreme spinner is
available i just can't do anything but
build this coaster it's just so much fun
to build every time it's an amazing
coaster in real life actually
i have something to report about but
yeah i'll do that in a second but yeah
it's just such a fun coaster to build
it's so versatile you can do live tails
you can do launches and it has great
stats as well and in this case i figured
it would be a really good coaster to
have it snake around the park interact
with
everything that it can interact with so
it gets interaction with the parts we
have in the future we will have a path
going straight through its vertical
loops that's really interesting but then
it can do some interaction with the
buildings and scenery like that as well
so it's going to fly over and through
some buildings too and finally of course
we've got really interesting terrain
here so it's definitely going to have
some terrain interaction too you've got
that part after the launch you know you
launch into a zero g roll and then go
into a helix that kind of reminds me of
superman and iron retailer at six flags
fiesta texas where the coasters
go over these cliff sides that are that
are made from this quarry that the park
is located in which kind of gives some
similar terrain interactions as this
park does i think
um so that's really cool as well and
then later on we're definitely gonna
build more buildings and paths around
this coaster as well
but yeah what i quickly wanted to talk
about is
right now i'm i i'm recording a video
for the first time building one of these
coasters when i've actually been on one
of them in real life as well
so this summer me and my friend joey
went to blobsalons belgium to ride
what's it called again right to
happiness
which is a tomorrowland themed extreme
spinner and
as it stands it's only one of two
extreme spinners in the world but from
the general consensus that i've heard
and seen and read and from anybody i've
talked to who has been on both coasters
it seems to be
about the best one in the world
there's also a time traveler in silver
dollar city which was the first which
was open already a few years ago
but it seems definitely even judging
from povs that
right happiness is a little bit more
intense and it's got some absolutely
insane elements
overall i don't know if every coaster of
this type is going to be like right to
happiness but having been on that and
now imagining
what the extreme spinners that i built
in scenario mode are going to be like
for guests is really fun the zero g roll
is undoubtedly going to be amazing i
remember riding the
540 degree twist that alright to
happiness has and going absolutely crazy
how
whenever you get the right spin it just
somersaults you backwards and forwards
in insane ways that i've never
experienced on a roller coaster and even
experiencing air time is a crazy
experience and different every time ride
to happiness has
some of the strongest air time i've ever
experienced on a coaster but besides
that you never know what direction
you're gonna get the airtime in one time
you're backwards the other time you're
forwards and sometimes you're spinning
or you're sideways or in whatever
direction you're going it's absolutely
nuts and
we need more of these coasters in the
world
unfortunately i don't have much of a say
about that in the world but at least in
my scenarios i'm gonna build these
things for my guests whenever i can
because
i am instantly a huge fan
anyway that's uh that's it about the
coaster let me talk a bit more about
what other strategies i've got going on
for this whole area of the park
if you were a very observant viewer you
might have noticed that when i opened up
this park i had a continue button which
means that i was already playing this
park before and to be very frank
most of the times i would play test
these parks a little bit before passing
them on to sebastian and garrett to do
the finishing touches and in this case i
actually stuck with the layouts that i
had during my playtime session or or my
play test session so all the the path
work and the rides that i've placed at
the start of the map here are very
heavily based or loosely based on the
play test map that i built the theming
is completely different so that's
definitely its own thing for this
playthrough but i figured the layout
just worked too well with that teacups
ride sitting just beneath that cliff
corner and then putting a carousel over
here to have some amazing views on all
the sides and also the the path that
goes down from the the top of the
entrance there which is it's funny how
the entrance is actually at the highest
point of this whole park at least
elevation-wise
and it just kind of worked too well i
figured so i stuck with that it also
means that i have the stalls right next
to my delivery building which is
definitely gonna come in handy when it
comes to hauling goods to the shops so
all things considered
i thought it just worked too well not to
go for it again
besides this is a part where
there is no terraforming to be done so
while you can technically just tunnel
your pots into the ground i didn't want
to build any tunnels or at least try to
avoid tunnels as much as possible and if
i do use them keep them as short and you
know close to the cliff side as possible
because in a scenario where you can't
terraform
building tunnels everywhere just kind of
seems like cheating and i remember back
in rollercoaster tycoon scenarios where
you can't terraform wouldn't allow you
to go underground anyway because you
normally need to
terraform some way to even allow
yourself to go underground because you
needed those vertical cliff faces which
is not the case in parkitect so in that
sense it's a lot easier but for some
reason
i guess my rollercoaster tycoon
experienced mind feels like it's
cheating to build tunnels when you're
not allowed to terraform and i guess
it would also make sense given the fact
that these rocks are
well really natural heritage
that it would be kind of weird to just
go in and out of these things besides
i'm not sure if they could even support
all of this and i say this knowing full
well that we're within the suspense of
of disbelief that you know this is this
is all just a game anyway but i'm not
sure if these rock faces could really
support all of the weight of all these
rides and roller coasters probably not
because in real life the
the rock
pillars and stuff like that are created
through erosion and i think it's really
just wind erosion and the like so
given the fact that they're probably not
very
strong types of rock to erode like that
i also think they probably wouldn't give
a very good foundation to build all
kinds of shenanigans like this on but
who knows i am not a geologist that's
just my
kind of amateur take on the whole thing
um
so yeah that's as far as i went there
also i decided to build some stuff
outside of the rocks give it some extra
supports give it some extra rook work as
well which you'll see me do throughout
this scenario just to make it look a
little bit nicer
i don't hate the way that rocks in park
attacked have this kind of
stripes effects you see all of these
black and gray stripes on the rock on
the cliff sides which you know works
well enough for the cartoony aesthetic
but every now and then i feel like it's
nice to also add some different textures
on the sides
just to have some variety to it and
allow myself to put some detail into the
cliff faces as well
just because of how vertical everything
in this park is
most of the time a lot of your screen
space will be taken up just by cliff
faces so i feel like it would be kind of
lame not to decorate them a little bit
as well
now at this point you'll also notice
that i'm trying to add a huge variety of
colors too i basically just looked up
whatever chinese buildings i thought
were interesting and took color schemes
from all of them and just jumbled them
all together and i'm just kind of
haphazardly placing buildings everywhere
it's probably not the most authentic way
to create this chinese experience but i
thought it looked interesting and
especially from an above perspective it
really kind of gives the illusion or at
least that's what i attempted to do here
that you have this whole town uh built
on the cliff faces instead of just
a single palace or some kind of
uh
effort to to try and build something
that's coherent
i'm trying to make it seem like it's
been built in different ages or just
kind of growing organically into what it
is today
also i'm being very experimental with
the color sometimes you'll see me
recolor things every now and then just
to try and make everything fit together
but there are some different general
themes that you can probably
already see so for instance the um
the entrance building
together with the information kiosk and
also the tower over there which hides
well which supposedly hides an elevator
for people who can't walk the stairs
are all in the same style and then we
also have the big carousel building and
some buildings around that which have a
different color of wood and different
roof color and overall details and style
which i think actually also almost kind
of goes into a japanese aesthetic as
well but
that's the thing the japanese basically
got a lot of their architecture cues
from the chinese dynasties long ago a
while ago so
it all kind of comes from the same point
of view um but anyway it's it's a big
mix of colors and styles basically is
what i'm trying to say and sometimes it
took some try on error to make things
fit together and not seem too messy i'm
really trying to hit that balance of
where it seems organic and messy enough
but at the same time still like
everything is trying to adjust to each
other and not seem too weirdly out of
place if that makes any sense
and i think that's also part of the fun
of
going for a park that's inspired by
chinese architecture as opposed to
japanese is that you can use many of the
same kind of roof shapes and general
language of architecture
but one of the most clear distinguishing
distinguishing features of chinese
architecture compared to japanese is
that there's a lot more paint
japanese architecture tends to use
unpainted wood
except in some
cases where they do use red painted wood
sometimes
but they don't go with any crazy colors
like green and blue decorations and
these are things that you do see in
chinese architecture so it's a lot more
colorful
and in that sense also more interesting
to build i think also a little bit
harder because i was a little bit
well more unsure of what i could get
away with whereas with japanese you just
stick with the japanese color schemes
and you're pretty much always good to go
and it will always be
realistic especially if you're just
sticking to natural colors and unpainted
materials as they typically do in japan
but china has a different story another
way in which china is quite different is
in using more stone walls
which is something that you do find in
chinese architecture but
in japan
once you're above the foundations mostly
everything is from wood and paper
screens
also famously chinese architecture was a
lot quicker to adopt western imports
like furniture
tables and chairs and things like that
and as as a result you kind of got
different shape of rooms as well whereas
japan even to this day has held on a lot
more to their traditional styles of uh
even arranging buildings and rooms and
houses with shifting walls and
traditional japanese uh tables and
things like that
maybe i'm already getting off topic a
little bit
but i remember long ago already doing a
bunch of research on what the difference
is between
japanese korean and chinese architecture
are because while they look super
similar
if you do read up on the differences a
little bit you can usually tell them
apart if you see pictures of buildings
remember one of the the subtle
differences that you can find as well
for instance is that while japanese is
overall slightly more simple and one
part of that is that japanese
curved temple roofs will always have
straight sections in the middle of the
roof and will only start to curve
upwards at the edges and at the corners
whereas with korean architecture for
instance you can find buildings where
the roof curves for the entire length of
the building and you know these are just
some of the the subtle touches that
can really differentiate these tiles
none of this is going to be very
relevant to parchitect of course but if
you're building in a different game like
planet coaster it's definitely something
to keep in mind if you really want to
try and go for something authentic
and you know at the end i
haven't completely studied
asian studies or anything like that and
i'm no architect but
it's still fun to uh to talk about this
stuff but take everything i say with a
grain of salt of course and if you're
really interested in this kind of topic
definitely do your own research as well
but this goes for any youtuber never
trust whatever youtubers say especially
if they say it in a cool accent or with
very nice animated graphics
usually they're just spouting
nonsense
i i was gonna say a different word there
but you know have to keep it pg-13
anyway
let's get back to the topic at hand i i
i just always get distracted by so many
things we're getting into what i would
call the last section of this first
section of time-lapse which is
decorating this whole area and giving it
some of the final touches also working
on the station of the coaster and the
surroundings
so i'm adding some general decorations
on the paths some lanterns and benches
and lamps and all of that stuff just to
breathe some life into it and speaking
of life as you might have noticed at
this point the guests are basically in
full force and they're enjoying this
spinning coaster a lot and if you see my
budget on the bottom left
it's honestly way too good of a coaster
you know for a long time i was wondering
whether one coaster would even make this
park commercially viable
at the the whole first part of this time
lapse while i was building stuff i was
really really scared of building things
and having to lose everything just
because my park wouldn't make a profit
and at this point honestly i i couldn't
care anymore because clearly this
coaster was way too good and putting way
too much money in my pocket and already
at twenty thousand dollars with just one
coaster and a few flat rides with all of
the scenery being built at the same time
was kind of insane to me but i guess it
just kind of speaks to the power of the
extreme spinning coaster it's just
that good anyway when it comes to
building i normally don't copy paste a
lot it's something that i try to
resist doing as much as possible just to
make every building unique and
try to like come up with new ways of
making buildings while playing the
scenario a little bit as well but in
this case
there is just so much very particular
stuff going on with the basic shapes and
it took me so much effort to build some
of these roofs as well that i ended up
making a couple of blueprints of
different roof pieces and decorations
that i made just to make my life a
little bit easier and save some time you
know you gotta work smarter not harder
um
and it's always nice to have these
blueprints and then be able to recolor
them afterwards or
make some small adjustments just to make
buildings different
so that's the strategy that i'm going
with with
with this scenario
also the coaster station is basically
built in these in the exact same style
as the carousel building although of
course with a very different shape and
all together different look but the
color scheme is the same and i'm drawing
from the same pieces that i blueprinted
from the uh the carousel building so
hopefully that should give this whole
area some
um continuation and what is the
continuity there we go as well um also
this is the part where lots of roofs
start overlapping and all of these
overhanging roofs start creating these
layers this this park is very vertical
which is something that i love it's
something that i find very hard to add
to my scenarios when you're starting off
with a flat map but once you get that
verticality and you start having parts
that cross each other and interact with
rides and different levels and lots of
buildings stacked on top of each other
it's just so much fun to build and it's
so much fun to look at and it allows for
every part of the park to be this crazy
diorama where lots of stuff is going on
so yeah it's very time consuming i
already know that this is going to be my
longest episode ever in this whole
series and
probably my first time that i break
through the one hour mark although i say
that not having finished the rest of the
video yet so
we'll see if that's true um but i i
think so it's it's probably gonna happen
anyway at this point
i figured i would do something that i
always forget to do until the end of my
scenarios and actually build a staff
room you know this time i'm gonna try to
be a better employer uh i'm gonna give
my uh stuff bathroom breaks as well at
some point i'm probably gonna have
earned enough money to launch myself
into space with this extreme spinner and
you know that's gonna be another nice
bathroom break for my employees as well
so
i think we're only heading in the right
direction with this company so of course
this being a very heavily themed
scenario i wanted to heavily theme our
staff room as well and put lots of
decoration around it make that uh well
it's not ugly but make that yeah
actually pretty ugly staff room in the
game look very different and
unrecognizable from what it was
also
i wanted to put gold inspires on all the
buildings because
we're just that extravagant anything
that has a spire gets a golden spire
on top of it so
you know just extra decoration extra
color
lots of stuff going on that's what we're
here for
now i'm gonna skip ahead in the time
lapse a little bit to
skip to what is my favorite thing in
this whole playthrough so far and
no it's not this roof yet this is
actually
built just before i start building my
favorite thing in this playthrough but
it's um it's the start of things to come
for sure so here we have the mid-course
brake run for the extreme spinning
coaster and to be honest the height of
this mid-course brake run
is not really realistic because it's at
the same height as the zero g roll that
follows it so i think realistically if a
coaster were to stall on this brake run
and then continue afterwards
it wouldn't be able to complete the
track which is a huge oversight
which is technically not an oversight
because i realized that while i was
building this brake run but i figured
you know what
form over function for this one honestly
i couldn't care less
i just really wanted to have this brake
run here with a roof over it with right
next to the waterfall it just looked way
too cool and at least in the layout the
section that follows this mid-course
brake run is a lot shorter than the
section that's uh before it and the
launch is not a block section due to the
fact that it's not a chain lift and the
coaster train can't be stopped on top of
it so very rarely will a coaster train
have to stop on this block break it's
really only there so that i can
technically have enough block sections
to run two trains
that said
there is the possibility that a train
will start on this thing but you know in
that case i'm just gonna
approach this thing as some real-life
coasters do that have messed up block
break sections
and
take it you know for what it is we're
gonna have to do some evacuations every
now and then i think that's a worthy
price to pay for a layout that looks way
too cool to do something else also i
know i could have left out the zero zero
after the block break section but
also that thing just looks way too cool
and the way that both of the helixes
before and after the zero g roll end up
spinning around the terrain pillars and
i swear this is something i didn't come
up with when i was designing this
scenario but it all just fits way too
well anyway after that i decided to
build
the most ambitious building in this
playthrough so far so
i've built many pagodas in parchitects
but
i've mostly just built japanese pagodas
which is nice because japanese pagodas
are very simple they're typically just
three or five or seven floors in some
crazy cases there used to be ninth floor
pagodas as well but that's already
besides the point uh but japanese
pagodas are nice and simple they don't
have many floors and they're
basically just square
they're quite simple in terms of their
shape so they're very easy to make in
park text in fact i even have a lego set
of tokyo that has a pagoda in it and
it's one of the easiest things to build
in lego and it just looks right you can
look at it and know that it's a pagoda
it just works
whereas with chinese pagodas there is
more variety in their designs there are
many different types of chinese pagodas
but typically
there are also
hexagon shapes which in parchex given
the fact that this game is not a huge
fan of diagonals
even though they are in the game but
they're a lot more limited in general as
a piece than straight pieces it just
makes things a lot harder
but i've really really wanted to build
one of these
iconic
hexagon pagodas that you see in china
with a crazy color scheme as well so
that's what i ended up doing
and this thing is gonna have to be built
almost exclusively out of basic shapes
of course i'm using some pillars as well
for the vertical pillars obviously some
of the wooden posts that this pagoda has
but the bulk of the work is all done by
basic shapes
and actually while building this thing i
found that the most difficult thing was
to make sure that the measurements were
right
i didn't want to build this thing and
make it look inconsistent like certain
floors were taller or lower than others
or
were offset more than others so this is
gonna have to be a completely straight
pagoda where every floor is one-fourth
of a grid space
smaller than the floor
below it on all four sides technically
it's all eight sides but
you know the the grid is a square grid
so on all four sides and then just
connecting the sides um
and yeah that's basically that this just
made me wonder if it's possible to
do make a theme park game or switch to a
hexagon grid that would be absolutely
insane i mean it's possible technically
hexagons actually no
they don't i'm sorry i messed up this
whole part that i was talking just now
it's an octagon i'm sorry for anybody
who's been face bombing themselves in
this whole time
octagons have eight sides hexagons have
six sides anyway that was uh that was my
brain part of my part i'm sorry but
there is no way to build an uh to build
an octagon grid there is a way to build
a hexagonal grid though but i'm not sure
if that's as useful in building i'm
getting very off topic again so yeah the
this is an octagon
uh pagoda and as you can see at this
point every floor is clearly one-fourth
of a grid space smaller than the one
below it so you really get that nice uh
straight tapering form um and once we
get to the top floors everything's
becoming a little bit easier to connect
to each other as well because the way
that diagonal and straights basic shapes
connect to the to each other in this
game can sometimes be a little bit
tricky and given the fact that both the
walls and the roofs and even some of the
red horizontal wooden details of this
pagoda are all made out of basic shapes
there was a lot of trying to work out
how to make these things fit together
and connect on a grid but in the end we
got there so i'm pretty happy with that
and really at this point i'm just
starting off with the general shape of
the of the pagoda really trying to work
out how to make this roof and how to
also make it look convincing
but at this point i was pretty happy
with how it turned out
and the overall shape was in place so it
was time to try and add some detail to
it and some finishing touches and really
make it look the part
so one of the things that i tried doing
is adding some paper windows to this
thing
at least some different colors so that
the walls wouldn't be entirely white and
i would actually have some other colors
to play with as well
so i'm putting that between the
different floors with the basic shapes
as well
and then of course
the fact that we're working with lots of
red wooden details means that we can
always add more pillars and stuff like
that but i decided to forgo that because
well i think it just worked well enough
this way and with how every floor tapers
off it would be really hard to add more
detail without the tower looking
inconsistent
and at this point i think
it's looking consistent and while i
could make while i could add more detail
i think consistency is really key here
so sticking with how the tower looks at
this point
it's time to head to my final project
of this time lapse anyway and then i
promise i'll finally give a quick
real-life overview and
check how the coaster works and what the
pov is like and all that good stuff but
first
i want to work on a station for another
coaster that's not here yet but i had a
station for it in mind so i decided to
build the station before i built the
coaster which is not something i
normally do but here i just had to do it
because there was this idea for the
whole scene that you have here with a
big building with the pagoda right next
to it and that huge building would be
perfect for a eurofighter station which
is a
coaster type that needs this huge white
station look and then you also need to
build a queue and then exit right next
to it so
generally speaking you need a building
that's at least five tiles wide so i
knew if i wanted to build a eurofighter
in my park this would have to be one of
the biggest buildings
so just to make sure that it fits right
i decided to create this whole scene and
try to work out how the layout will go
later i honestly have no idea what the
layout for this coaster is going to be
yet i'm going to figure that out soon
enough but at least for now we've got a
station going
also and
i'm not sure why i keep doing this but
maybe it's just
for my own sense of immersion but all of
the buildings that i'm building here
even if this game is from an isometric
perspective
are technically completely fully
supported and you should be able to look
inside these buildings and not have to
notice any glaring missing things
so before i built the roof i built this
whole pillar structure around the
building that the roof is going to be
laid on top on
on top of
and also made a new blueprint for the
roof just so that i wouldn't have to
build this thing completely from scratch
because this roof is
absolutely huge and it's using
lots of corner pieces which are some of
the hardest pieces to work with in this
whole style of doing asian roofs but
also i'm pretty happy with how it turned
out the way that the shape of the
building works definitely
manages to avoid the biggest potential
hurdle with coaster stations that is the
station looking like a rectangle
which with all of these decorations and
parts jutting out i was pretty thankful
didn't happen even with this rectangular
top part
speaking of which i got a lot of
inspiration for this actually from some
real-life chinese buildings
specifically something that i saw on
i think it was yeah facebook actually
recently
um so i actually took a little bit to
look at my facebook again there because
i saved it a while ago but yeah so
basically the city of chongqing which is
one of the biggest cities in china and
an absolute mega city which i think many
people around the world forget kind of
exists or don't know at all has really
interesting architecture because it's a
city really built on hills it's got
metro lines going through buildings and
ridiculous things like that but it also
has an old town center
that's located on the hillside
and it has some really amazing buildings
uh with really interesting walls and
just lots of details that you can copy
for anything chinese inspired so
generally if you're building
anything chinese in a game like
architects i would highly recommend
looking at the city but even if you
don't it's such a cool city to just look
up pictures of because it has crazy
situations where you've got roads on top
of buildings and
it's just insane it's one of the most
vertical cities in the world probably
definitely of its size
anyway with all that said
let's get back into a quick real-time
section and see what the park is
actually like after all this development
i think this is my longest time-lapse
section ever so
apologies for that long sit but let's
take a look at how this thing turned out
so far
so here we are after a bunch of color
changes i think i've arrived at a color
scheme that i like for this general area
so
it's pretty simple honestly it looks a
lot more complicated than it really is
just because of all the scenery
kind of hiding stuff but in reality
everything's quite flat of course
i am trying to connect different levels
with lots of different paths but it's
really the buildings that that make this
look more
uh intricate than it really is but still
i love the layeredness that you get as a
result of the terraforming in this park
and real quick let's follow the coaster
and see where it goes how it goes
so first off we start off with the
launch with a 0g roll right over the
entrance area
into this kind of strange wonky turn
around element
on a different
well terraforming platform i suppose
with the loop here going through what's
going to be some kind of future
connection to a different part of the
park now i'm quickly going to turn
around because i do think you get some
better views of this part this
perspective
and then we slide on over to the
waterfall where we have the mid-course
brake run
into this
bazaar kind of corkscrew contraption
which i did rework a little bit i don't
know if i featured that in a time lapse
but i think i didn't just to make it a
bit smoother and make sure it wasn't as
ridiculously snappy as it used to be
also this is really just a trim break if
i remember correctly just to get this
thing up to the right speed um
but yeah it's it's not something that's
super important otherwise
so that's it for the layout of the
coaster and then for the layout of the
rest of the park i think i'm mostly
going to follow this general theme for
basically all of the areas of the park
just keep on building these kinds of
houses see what other rides and flat
rides i can fit in here
but most importantly i want to see what
i can do with this area which will
probably be a bit more
you know um consistent in terms of style
because the very idea of all of this is
that it's it's just kind of random
buildings that are built over time and
you get a sort of town look to it
whereas this could be some kind of
temple complex or or something like that
so it's all going to be a bit more
consistent and of course in the future
this is going to be a eurofighter
station so i have no idea how that
layout is going to go because i built
the station before i built the rest of
the layout but
i'm going to try and figure something
out
anyway let's keep going and see where we
end up
so completely different topic by the way
that i just wanted to quickly talk about
i recently had a very small discussion
with some people on discord what kind of
things people do while they're watching
my videos
that sounds kind of weird but basically
i mean do you just completely watch
these videos with your full attention or
do something different in the meantime i
hear many people just watch my videos
while playing games themselves and just
put it on a second screen or something
like that or i've read many people who
post comments that they watch my videos
while they're in bed to fall asleep
apparently my voice is very conducive to
that i'll take it as a compliment
but yeah i'm always kind of curious
especially for videos like this one
which is extremely long i couldn't
imagine having your complete attention
you know focused on this video maybe
even have to break it up in parts i
don't know um anyway that that's just my
little ramblings about that now let's
talk about the layouts for this coaster
real quick because this thing gave me a
headache like
i started off with so many ideas that
just completely didn't work and i think
that's just sort of the thing that
happens when you build layouts without a
prior idea of where you can place
certain elements usually when i start
building things you know at least get a
general idea of this is where the lift
hill can be this is where the first drop
is going to be and especially if you
have to work with difficult terrain
you can kind of plan out some kind of uh
plan to company of you know where i'm
gonna where am i gonna go with this
thing with this one i i had no idea and
that certainly didn't work out very well
for the first few
attempts i tried to do a first drop over
the water right next to the waterfall
doing it straight or curved or something
like that all of that really didn't work
so
i eventually ended up with this solution
where the coaster goes down a little bit
has a sort of pre-drop part where it
meanders a bit and then you go into a
mid-course break run before you get into
the actual layout
and then funnily enough it it drops down
with a vertical drop which is of course
what euro fighters do but this is not
really a typical year fighter because it
doesn't start off with a vertical lift
hill it just does a vertical drop from a
cliff side
into a slightly more typical eurofighter
fair although it is of course trying to
snake around these different
pillar terrain things and
i was really making this hard for myself
but i wanted to make sure that this
coaster would explore this whole valley
and i wanted to give it decent realistic
smooth elements but at the same time i
had to dodge all of these stupid terrain
pillars everywhere and try to avoid
accidentally building tunnels so
yeah there was a lot of trying to figure
out how pieces could fit together and
eventually also get back into the
station
while leaving enough room for the whole
path network that i needed to even get
to the station in the first place
because you do have that uh path leading
uh
up to this area from the entrance ending
on that little terrain pillar that you
see in the the bottom right of the
screen so this whole thing was just a
giant logistical puzzle and
i i honestly don't know how real-life
theme parks like fantasia land for
instance
do that insane stuff where they try to
make all of the buildings and rides and
parts fit into a certain space because
it's it's really difficult honestly
working with a flat scenario is
so much easier and it gives you
well fewer headaches but at the same
time i would say
this is exactly the kind of thing i like
as a challenge in a scenario and i think
it usually makes you a little bit more
creative
as well and it's it's something that
really helped out in this layout for
instance
the way that the the beginning and the
ending of this layout work with that
drop from the cliff side and stuff like
that
that never would have happened without
this terrain so while it's really
difficult and you often find yourself
not being able to do things that you
want to do at first
when you take that time that you're
forced to take to to think about it more
and and figure out solutions for it you
very often end up with things that are
much more interesting than what you were
originally going for
um
at least i i tend to think that it goes
like this in my experience so
that's part of the fun of scenarios like
these i think and
why i'm pretty happy with how this has
worked out because it's it's a really
unique take on terraforming uh
not just in real life these are very
unique mountains but in the game it just
creates this strange gameplay mechanic
as well and that actually reminds me to
talk about something that i haven't
really talked about in this video so far
but that's actually kind of a key part
of my whole philosophy with how i'm
tackling this scenario um you might have
noticed and it's definitely
a big part of everything that i've been
doing so far but
i'm trying to keep all of the paths on
top of the the
terrain pillars and the plateaus and
whatever kind of things they are anyway
the paths are always at the high
elevation and then the coasters are the
only things that are ever dropping down
to uh the quote-unquote ground
and to these parts between the mountains
so
i decided to keep it very strictly
separated this way because i knew that
you know keeping all of the paths and
rides on top of these hills would make
them super crammed and i think the the
more empty areas with just a few trees
and coasters between all of these areas
on top of the hills uh works out to
balance the look of this scenario a
little bit
i think there are very few things which
are worse than looking at a park in
parkitect where everything is detailed
and there's stuff to look at everywhere
like a giant where's waldo drawing um
it's just very confusing the eye doesn't
really know where to look at and
it's part of you know a painting to try
and figure out a certain
area or object or whatever you're you're
trying to get the eye to focus attention
on first and i think it's kind of
similar in definitely theme parks in
real life but even to an extent in
isometric games like park text where you
can't just fill the screen with things
everywhere you need some
some areas of less focus here and there
to to try and direct people's eyes and
yeah that's kind of what the
the background uh works for in this
scenario i suppose the lower areas are
really just kind of the background to
the foreground uh that's that's on top
of these hills with all of the buildings
and the parts and
rides and all of that good stuff
so yeah yeah that was uh that was my
thought process going into this scenario
and that's why i'm really trying to cram
everything on top of these hills and why
certain areas of the park are just
extremely busy and other areas are much
more open and i leave almost empty and
i've talked about this a little bit with
robo park as well but i think the effect
is much more important in this scenario
and especially given the fact that it's
a really big scenario with a very unique
set of terrain
i think it's very important to try and
pay some attention to where you're
actually placing your detail
anyway moving on
i decided to finish the big temple
complex thingamajig that the eurofighter
is located in
by building a giant building for the
block breaks at the end of the ride
which
i suppose in real life you know if i
wanted to do this thing completely
realistically good hands for
what could house the transfer track i
think my brain just kind of
merged two words there um but yeah in
this case i'm not going quite into that
detail but it still you know kind of
creates the illusion of a giant set of
buildings that are housing all kinds of
important stuff for this coaster and
kind of giving it a home base and it's
also interesting how it gets a really
unique interaction because
it means the block breaks are on top of
the first drop of the coaster and i
don't think there's a single roller
coaster in the world where that happens
it's a really
unique setup here i suppose you could
say that the very gentle small drop
coming out of the station is the first
drop of the ride but let's be realistic
here it doesn't really work that way
the drop coming out of the building here
is definitely the first drop
so it's a very unique
set of
very unique general layout here but i
think it kind of works to make the first
drop a little bit more interesting as
well first you just have this high
altitude area where you do a curve and
an s-bend then you move into the
building and it means you can't really
see the drop all that clear you can
barely even see that you're going to
drop and then you come out of the
building
and just after breaking a little bit
because there is a block break over
there
you crash vertically into the cliff side
and you start the
kind of insane layout of this coaster so
i think yeah it kind of works in this
setting
um
and then i decided to you know connect
these two buildings with some roofs
which also double as the q cover because
there is very little space on this hill
um i keep calling them hills and
mountains but honestly i i wouldn't know
what to call these things plateaus
they don't really make sense they're
almost kind of like islands and in a way
i'm really treating them with islands as
islands with bridges in between them and
trying to fit everything as tightly as
possible as i can on these islands
anyway yeah there's very little space
left on this island hill mountain
whatever you want to call it
so the queue just kind of has to be
placed inside this building to leave
just enough space around these buildings
to also leave it a little bit more open
and have some greenery and foliage and
stuff over there
because as always i'm trying not to
every single square
of these things with parts and things
that are necessary gotta have some
emptiness in there as well
and now it's time to bridge the gap
between this big island mountain hill
thing i need to stick with a certain
word you know what i'm just gonna call
them
islands yeah because that's basically
what they are
you know at least at least for my paths
and stuff so i'm covering the
the gap for this uh between these two
islands with another bridge i had to
keep this one more simple than i wanted
to i was trying to come up with all
kinds of elaborate designs in my head
and testing out a few things and then i
realized wait a second the coaster is
passing right underneath these things
and if i built any kind of supporting
structure
other than just
straight stone beams on this thing
the the heads of guests on the coaster
would surely crash into the bridge
which wouldn't be very nice so i decided
to keep this thing very simple but of
course i wanted to come up with a
slightly different design for this
bridge than everything so far
so what i'm going with is
a kind of simple stone base and then a
very simple
red fence as well which is not as tall
and detailed as most of the fences in
this map but you know it's another
slight variation on some other designs
so i think it was better to to keep this
one a bit more simple and try and go
with some of the fancier ones that you
see throughout this scenario
now
at this point i was trying to figure out
how this coaster would work in terms of
block breaks because it's
a little bit tricky to get this thing to
work right um because there's not really
a proper mid-course break run and
instead there's a block break very
shortly after the station and there's a
bunch of block breaks right after the uh
the end of the layout so
eventually i got the right timing on
this thing to make sure that the cars
would never wait too long on any of the
block brakes but i'm still making use of
as much throughput as i can because
that's definitely something you have to
watch out for when you're building your
fighters those things at least the
trains themselves have a very small
capacity
now at this point i
decided it was time to go back to an
area of the park i haven't tackled in
quite a while because i just didn't know
what to do with it and to be completely
honest when i started building this i
still wasn't completely sure i just had
some ideas i tested with some flat rides
in this area and
figured it was the best thing to do and
just gave it a shot from there
i decided to place the riptide because
it just looked the best
i could have placed a pirate ship here
but i think that would have made no
sense given the theme of the scenario i
didn't want to place any anything too
tall in here either because it would
drop the because it would block the view
of the temple
from this part of the park which you
know of course is not really a concern
for me myself but
for any of the guests walking in that
area of the park it would just ruin the
weenie that is the temple um also these
are the kind of moments that kind of
make me wish
that you know you could look at park
text as a 3d game and from the
perspective of the guests and i know
there are mods to do this thing but
i am sticking to the completely vanilla
game for this campaign play through
not to cheat
or show anything that isn't possible
with the base game so
that's how it is
but at the same time i feel like this
would actually be such a cool sight line
and i did try to work it out as such
because even though you can't really see
from the perspective of guests in this
game i still think it makes sense to try
and design things from the perspective
of guests because that's something that
real life theme parks do and if you end
up you know at least taking it into
consideration i think you'll end up with
some more realistic layouts um so for
instance placing your weenies at the end
of a main street things like that which
happen in real life because that's how
perspective works um you should
definitely try to copy those things in
partick as well even if it's just an
isometric game
now here i started supporting
the backside of the the coaster here i
wasn't too sure what to do with it for a
while but decided eventually this was
probably the best way to go about doing
uh this thing just to get rid of the
coaster's own supports
and then there's a little bit of rock
work and foliage work to do over here as
well i ended up placing lots of rock
besides the cliffs that you start out
with in this scenario because
it just looks so much better if you kind
of intersperse the in-game terraforming
with the in-game rock pieces and really
trying to make those rock pieces huge so
you can make some interesting
textures and shapes on the sides of
those cliffs and make them look a little
bit more realistic
but it's definitely something that i
sunk quite a bit of time into
during this playthrough not to mention
that i could only get away with this
stuff because i'm earning loads of money
because big rocks and architects are
very expensive
if you're watching this and you don't
have any experience with this in the
game itself you can you know recolor and
reshape any objects you want in this
game but reshaping objects makes them
more expensive as well and that stuff
like exponentially increases costs of
rock work if you make your rocks huge
you can easily place uh pay hundreds of
dollars just for a single rock piece
that way and well just go ahead and
figure out how many rock pieces i'm
sinking into all of these cliff faces
it's a lot of money i'm sinking into
scenery and
probably
i would reckon this scenario probably
has some of the most expensive scenery
if not the most expensive scenery i've
ever done in a scenario and really i
have to give props to the spinning
coaster for being an absolute statistics
beast
and just earning me all of this cash
because
it wouldn't be possible without the
spinning coaster
anyway going back to this area of the
park i
finally figured out what i wanted to do
with the smallest empty spot that was
left here i decided just to build a very
typical shaped asian merchant house
it's going to be the only building with
this shape in the map which is kind of
funny because you see
many buildings with this kind of shape
in china and japan
but you know it's it's a more standard
shape really you'll find that the only
buildings in asia which really feature
those super lavish lush rounded
decorated roofs are typically religious
buildings and the like
very special places
or palaces
it's not something that you'll find
everyday buildings having and that
little building over there was a little
bit more of an everyday building type of
design
i
i know that sounds very vague
but
i i didn't look too much into it either
it's park tech what can i say um
and finally i wanted to build hopefully
the last ride of this scenario i know
i'm barely even at 400 guests but
at this time i was placing all of my
bets on advertisements being able to to
pull through and getting me to 800
guests after i finished this ride alone
if that wouldn't happen then i'm kind of
screwed i'm gonna have to come up with a
way to retrofit this park with more
rides but
i'm fairly certain you know it's gonna
happen no spoilers
but yeah um i didn't show any footage of
me building this ride because i forgot
to record it
it's as simple as that
sometimes it'd just be like that
that said it's not super interesting i
guess it's just a powered coaster it
does some turns it does some helixes it
goes up it goes down it
it's it's it's at a speed it speeds
along the layouts
that's basically what it does honestly
powered coasters are not that
interesting in real life i just wanted
to build one of these in this scenario
because i don't build many of them which
is probably probably because i'm not a
huge fan of them in real life
but in park tech they can actually come
through and you can make some really
interesting layouts with them
take for instance this layout you don't
have to worry about a lift hill
which is something that you know i
didn't see a logical place for anywhere
on this map
or at least this part of the map but i
didn't have to worry about it because
this is a powered coaster you can put
this thing anywhere you want you can
make it go anywhere you want and you can
just set a speed for it so when it comes
to themed areas and trying to cram
coasters uh into certain spaces i think
they work really well
and also i know i've been hating on the
powered coaster a little bit now but i
think this is one of the one of the
things they do best is is be integrated
into general themed areas
because they don't have to worry so much
about the way that their layout is going
i've seen and written many part courses
that do really interesting things with
scenery interaction with other rides and
with paths and that's always that's
always really fun
um
so yeah these things these things aren't
so bad it's just that
i'm gonna have to be honest
roller coasters powered by gravity are
just more fun uh hell there are just
even people who argue that these things
aren't really roller coasters because
while they are semi-powered by gravity
because they do go
faster and slower depending on going up
and down certain parts of the track they
are powered very much in the same way a
dark ride would be so it's it's it's the
everlasting conflict of what's a roller
coaster what isn't
it's it's always fun to uh to discuss
i tend to be of the opinion by the way
that anything that's on roller coaster
database is a roller coaster with the
exception of butterflies butterflies are
not roller coasters for anybody who's in
the know
or who's not in the know actually i
should say
butterflies are basically playground
equipment they
bring you up a little hill and then you
start swinging from side to side but
because you're on a vehicle and it has
wheels and it's powered by gravity rcdb
says it's a roller coaster i say that's
nonsense
anyway i'm getting very off topic
the actual last ride of this scenario
that i almost just forgot about is the
drop tower
and i suppose this would be an
intermittent drop tower in real life the
roto drop as it used to be known in
roller coaster tycoon as well
and
i wanted to go for this drop tower
specifically because it's perfectly on
the grid which meant that i could place
my little chinese roof on that thing and
add some decoration to it which is a
little bit cheesy uh i'll show it a
little bit at the end of this video but
yeah it's it's it's definitely something
um but i figured it was better than
nothing and i've always wanted to try
and play around with it because to my
knowledge i have never
really themed
a drop tower like that i've definitely
kind of pimped some of them
but not this specific type and i think
not with a theme like this um
but maybe i i need to refresh my memory
on things i've done in the past i'm
pretty sure of it
so i'm keeping everything else on this
island very simple we just have a queue
and some simple decorations around this
thing i had i had to kind of watch out
uh with these roofs not hitting people
in the face as they dropped down from
this thing because
the corners that i made for these
chinese roofs really stick out almost a
full tile which meant that people's face
would be hit by a beam which at you know
the high speeds of a drop tower wouldn't
be super comfortable
so eventually i just ended up cutting
the ends of this roof off which doesn't
even look too bad and it kind of makes
this roof unique in the map so
all things consider it uh all things
considered i i i consider it a pretty
decent job there
and finally um it's time to pimp this
island a little bit add some rock work
to it some foliage
make the paths a little bit nicer
and yeah that's basically everything i
ended up doing for this scenario so
let's cut to the final bit of real-time
footage and see how this park ended up
so every time i do this i wonder to
myself whether this is one of those
scenarios where you have to hold the
goals for a while or you can just do
them instantly
looks like we can just do them all at
once yeah there we go awesome so that's
dragon valley and
well as i expected it went into over an
hour of time lapse
even though i was already trying to cut
out some footage but you know it is what
it is this is also one of my favorite
scenarios so far i think it's it's my
favorite results from everything in the
taste of adventure dlc so far
but
man it's been a lot of work to get here
let's quickly close this video off with
some povs of some of the coasters
let's start off with a vertical drop
coaster
so as we know we get this interesting
element here where we kind of slow down
a bit on the brakes over there before we
go into the the drop here i eventually
turned those block brakes into regular
brakes even though they started off as
block brakes just to make sure that the
cars wouldn't stop there for too long if
anything went wrong or if the coasters
started breaking down or anything like
that
um but yeah after that we just have a
meandering layout going through the
valley
as of course the strategy is to keep all
of the parts on top of the hills and
have the coasters go through the valley
and i think this
more or less works for it it's not
really a euro fighter per se and i think
if we had infinity coasters in this game
i probably would have gone for an
infinity coaster on this one
that said it's still fun to have that
typical vertical drop and the the lift
hill is almost a euro fighter lift hill
maybe just not quite but you know it's
getting there
and then of course we have the powered
coaster let's give it a quick pov as
well
i actually
i never noticed these little icons hold
up i think
i think these are uh speed icons
indicating where which
yeah yeah that's cool actually i never
noticed that about the powered coaster
because the way that the powered coaster
works is you have different segments you
set at different speeds so for this one
i set the speed at the lowest parts the
highest
and then up here it's still a little bit
you know
slower and then once you get into the
second part of the layout into this
helix after this big drop it reaches the
max speed um i didn't know you had these
little things indicating where the speed
would change that's really interesting
also i'm sorry if i totally went off
topic there it's just something i never
noticed but yeah this is just a powered
coaster as you're kind of used to these
things although i think it's a little
bit more intense than you usually
see these layouts being in real life
first off the layout is not too fast but
then we get into this
well kind of crazy helix segment here
and then some interaction with the
spinning coaster and finally a very
steep hill back into the station where
it actually kind of naturally slows down
as well and then we go back for a second
round
so
honestly i'm not gonna show that whole
second round but that's the powered
coaster also it has a kind of simple
station to be very honest at this point
i was kind of done with this whole theme
and doing these buildings that said i do
think this is probably one of my
favorite buildings it's it's not the
most most interesting per se but
if i were to continue building in this
style i would consider this one of the
example buildings it's very typical it
uses the roofs it has the simple
decoration top it's it's it's a simple
shape but it just kind of works and i
put a lot of foliage around it to to
make it feel like it's not too much part
of a village like
these parts of the park are or this part
but it still works it still functions as
a decent station building i think
and then of course we have the buildings
for the eurofighter which
is this giant temple complex which works
out pretty well i think uh for one we
have the block breaks over here which
are all at the end of the layout so in
case anything goes wrong at least the
trains can stack over here and not in
the middle of the layout
and we have this
interesting view at the back as well i
decided to support this piece of track
with some wooden bracing beams as
opposed to using the in-game supports
because i thought it would keep this
interesting cliff face intact and even
though this is the back side of this
temple and it really is intended as such
i wanted to at least make it look
interesting from that side as well
but really this view over here is is the
main attraction of this park definitely
also kind of made to be a thumbnail i
know this is not something i mentioned
very often but usually when i'm building
i also try to think of what areas could
be the thumbnail for the video and this
is just
there's rarely been a more clear
contender than this one i also like the
the bit of interaction it ends up
getting here when you cross underneath
the block brakes to do the first drop
that's definitely a very unique setup
and it's the kind of thing where
i wouldn't have come up with that you
know if it weren't for just the creative
limitations of the map basically forcing
me to do that uh so it's it's something
that just kind of happens but i think it
worked out pretty decently
uh and then we have the drop tower which
honestly i'm not sure if i'm a big fan
of this thing it looks a little bit
silly um but it's it's really too big of
a structure to completely enclose in a
building without making it look weird
so
this is a at least something that was an
attempt at theming this thing
so yeah that's uh that's it for dragon
valley i think i'm mostly done showing
you all of this stuff
let's quickly head back um actually i'm
gonna save before i leave um there you
see my multiple saves just to make sure
that i never end up with a save that's
going to be a dead end but let's quit
and see what's the trophy
that's interesting let's see what the
trophy is for this map it kind of
glitched out for a second there all
right so it's the building that is just
out of uh
out of reach for this actual map but i
think that works all right and then we
go to the next one which if i remember
correctly is
is it this one
yeah there we go it's victoria island
so that's going to be interesting um not
quite going to tell you why well i guess
you can read
i guess we're not going to be able to uh
to buy up all of the remaining land
because it's gonna be super expensive so
another one of these scenarios where the
um the amount of available land to build
on is gonna be part of the challenge but
you know that's not something for next
time this video is long enough as it is
wait a second there's a floating ship i
only just noticed that anyway i'm gonna
close the video here thanks for watching
guys and i'll see you in the next
episode